Speaker 1: . We have now learned that Donald
Trump had the opportunity to go after al Qaeda
terrorist Ayman al-Zawahiri when he was president.
Joe Biden recently making the decision to
strike al-Zawahiri, killing him.
But Donald Trump chose not to do it because
he didn't recognize the name.
These are now the widespread reports.
Business Insider.
Trump had the chance to kill Al Qaida's leader,
but didn't because he didn't recognize the
name.
The Al Qaida leader, Ayman al-Zawahiri, was
killed by a U.S. drone strike, Biden announced
Monday.
Then President Trump had the option to kill
al-Zawahiri but chose not to, NBC reported
in 2020.
Trump wanted to kill Osama bin Laden's son
instead because it was the only name he knew.
Can you imagine?
Intelligence officials briefed Trump many
times about senior terrorist figures that
the CIA wanted to track down and kill mentioning
al-Zawahiri.
Two people familiar with the briefings told
NBC that Trump chose not to pursue al-Zawahiri
because he didn't recognize his name.
He instead said, Let's go after Hamza bin
Laden.
He would say, I've never heard of any of these
people.
What about Hamza bin Laden?
A Pentagon official told the news outlet that
was the only name he knew.
The Department of Defense and a spokesperson
for Trump did not immediately respond to insider's
request for comment.
Even though bin Laden's son was widely seen
as an emerging figure in the terrorist group.
He was not believed to be planning any attacks
at the time.
The president's preference for a celebrity
targeted killing.
Not surprising.
And listen, bottom line, Trump didn't perceive
that there was anything in it for him and
Trump probably rightly assessed.
I think this is almost certainly true.
If Trump doesn't recognize the name, he assumes
a lot of his followers don't either.
That that's probably accurate.
But also understand that Trump could make
a big deal out of whatever.
You know, he can come out and say, you know
who we got?
We got J.P. Ailes.
Oh, no, I'm sorry.
Ayman al-Zawahiri.
We got him.
And this guy was a big deal.
Bad guy.
I sometimes would call him Abdoul, as he often
says during his speeches, and his followers
would have said, look, he got J.P. al-Zawahiri
or whatever the guy's name is.
I think that that probably would work.
But to some degree, there's this What's in
it for me?
And killing someone whose name is bin Laden
is probably better.
This also, by the way, supports the reasoning
for Trump authorizing the drone strike on
the Iranian general.
Better headlines.
It might incite Iran.
Maybe it makes his Saudi friends happy.
You know, who knows?
And sometimes you have to understand the two
filters.
One is, is there something in it for me?
Which Trump asks.
The second part then, is Trump might not recognize
that there's something in it for him.
And so if we think back to COVID, if Trump
had simply said, masks are patriotic, we're
printing 5 million exclusive MAGA masks only
to be made available to my best and biggest
subscribers.
And then we're just going to follow what doctors
say.
He would have made big money.
We know he makes big money off of the MAGA
hats.
He would have gotten reelected.
I mean, it really is that simple.
And maybe we'll talk about that tomorrow with
political scientist Rachel Bitter Cofer as
well.
And by the way, he might have saved 100,000
or 150,000 or even more lives in so doing.
But Trump doesn't always recognize when there's
something in it for him.
We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2192.
David P. A very good question about monkeypox.
You know, a lot of right wingers, including
Marjorie Taylor GREENE, who we spoke about
yesterday, are framing monkey pox as a gay
disease.
They're sort of talking about it like it's
the new aids or whatever.
And of course, it's merely coincidental that
this initial contagion group happened to be
among gay or bisexual men, but it is already
spreading beyond that.
And this caller asks a very good question.
Speaker 3: Hey, David.
Jeremy in Oregon here.
I just wanted to comment on that monkey pox
being a homosexual disease.
What are these conservatives that are saying
they're going to say when they come down with
it?
Are they gay?
Probably not.
And it will be dismissed as interested into
something else.
Yeah.
Conspiracy.
We were infected by George Soros or something.
Speaker 1: No.
So here's the deal.
At this point, it seems like the monkey pox
cat is out of the proverbial bag.
And we're already seeing people other than
gay men get it.
We're you know, some gay men also have children
and sometimes they pick up their kids.
And so it's obviously going to go bigger.
And the most there's a couple possibilities
for how the right will handle that.
One will be they'll say, okay, like first
that was from the COVID virus was from China.
But then thanks to China, it's spread everywhere.
They'll go with something similar.
They'll say gay men, seeded monkey pox in
our communities and now it's everywhere and
it never should have happened.
That's sort of one possibility.
The other possibility is, yeah, they'll just
pretend they never said the thing about it's
a gay disease.
They'll, you know, they're very comfortable
rewriting history, revisionist history.
That's a possibility.
And the third one is, yeah, some other conspiracy
theory.
So they'll move on to saying monkey pox is
being shot with some kind of Jewish gun.
By George Soros or something like that.
Something along those lines.
But they'll come up with something else whenever
you think they won't be able to talk their
way out of this one.
Because the only explanation they could come
up with, nobody would believe they come up
with an incredible explanation and their followers
believe it and they repeat it.
So there's we've never we still have not hit
rock bottom that I can assure you.
We have a tremendous bonus show for you today.
Top Democrats I'm sorry, top economists agree.
The health care and climate package that Democrats
want to pass will put downward pressure on
inflation.
Republicans should want it.
Right?
Right.
An Idaho abortion law has now drawn a Justice
Department lawsuit.
We will discuss why.
And thirdly, Joe Biden's task force has indeed
now reunited 400 migrant children separated
from their families under Trump.
It's been done quietly.
It's been done relatively efficiently, although
it does take some time to do it.
And we will talk about the implications and
the next steps on that.
On today's bonus show.
Don't miss the bonus show.
You can sign up at join Packman dot com.
It's one of many great membership benefits.
It now comes with an upgraded experience thanks
to some new elements of technology that we've
implemented on the member podcast.
Sign up today, use the coupon code big voting
22 to get a discount and I will see you then.